[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام كل عام وانتم
بالف خير
الم يذكر احد اعضاء مجلس الشعب السوري قبل
اشهر ان اكثر من مائه الف جندي وضابط من
الجيش السوري سقطوا في المعارك مع الجيش
الحر
الم يصل الامر ب رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الى التهكم على الجيش السوري
قائلين انه ثالث اقوى جيش في سوريا
الا تقود القوات الايرانيه والعراقيه وحزب
الله المعارك على الارض السوريه
كيف تتشدق او تتشدق وسائل الاعلام السوريه
بان الجيش استعاد زمام المبادره بينما خسر
خلال اربعه اسابيع فقط اكثر من مائه دبابه
رغم شح المعدات القتاليه لدى المعارضه
الم يحقق الجيش الحر انتصارات هائله بعد
معركه القصير في معظم انحاء البلاد يضيف
ضيفنا الم يعلن النظام عن معركه عاصفه
الشمال في حلب قبل اكثر من شهر لاعادتها
الى حضن الوطن
الا يقف الان عاجزا عن ادخال الطعام
لقواته المحاصره داخل المدينه يتساءل احد
المراسلين الميدانيين
لكن في المقابل الا يحقق الجيش العربي
السوري انتصارات سريعه في حمص وريف دمشق
الا يعاني الريف الدمشقي من حصار خانق
تفرضه القوات الحكوميه الم تتراجع معظم
القوى الغربيه عن وعودها بتسليح قوات
المعارضه المتعلم بريطانيا انها تخلت عن
الفكره بعد ان بدات الكفه تميل لصالح
الجيش النظامي الا تشهد صفوف قوات
المعارضه تخبطا متزايدا الم تبدا بال
تقاتل فيما بينها بدل مواجهه القوات
النظاميه الا تسير خطه النظام في استرجاع
المناطق الساقطه على قدم الوسائل اسئله
اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على المعارض
والناشط الميداني الدكتور خالد مصطفى وعلى
مدير مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه في طهران
السيد امير الموسوي
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تصدق ان الجيش السوري استعاده
زمام المبادره فعلا صوت على صفحه الاتجاه
المعاكس خمسه وثلاثون الفا وستمائه وواحد
وثمانون شخصا ثمانطاش فاصله سته نعم واحد
وثمانين فاصله اربعه الدكتور خالد لو بدات
معك ب بهذه النتيجه يعني ما الذي يجعل
هؤلاء يعني هؤلاء ال ال ال ال المصوتين
يعتقدون ان اه الجيش النظامي لم يستعد
زمام المبادره مع العلم اننا نسمع من
وسائل الاعلام الاخرى بان الجيش النظامي
يحقق انتصارات كبرى على الارض اه بادئ ذي
بدء اسمح لي انا اقف دقيقه صمت اجلالا
ارواح شهداء الوطن الاحرار شهداء الثوره
السوريه
الفاتحه على روح شهداء الوطن اه اه
الاجابه بكل بساطه عندك دكتور فيصل انا
اشكرك كل الشكر
انك الدليل انك اتيت بهذا الايراني
ايران
ارجوك هو يمثل نظام الان الدليل على ذلك
انك لم تجد ولا واحد في من من من من ال ال
في الضاله ان يدافع عن ما يسمى الجيش
السوري ودليل ذلك انه ايران هي التي لحرس
الثوره الايراني محتل ارض الشام الابيه
وقدرنا ان نواجههم على الارض وكذلك ان
نواجههم اعلاميا وجود هاي
يدافع عن النظام الايراني
خلينا بال بالموضوع هذا اكبر اكبر نتيجه
وجود هذا الرجل ان الجيش السوري ان دحر
والان هم الثوار الذين على الارض يبادرون
و زمام المبادره كيف لا اول ما انطلق
العمل الثوري في سوريا العمل العسكري في
باباعمرو من قريب السلام اه من نقطه
عسكريه واحده الان سوريا عباره عن جبهه
ملتهبه اليكم تريد من درعه اذا اتى
العلاقات من الارض من ايام قليله من كم كم
متى كانت هناك من حوالي اربعين واخواتي
المجاهدين والمقاتله على الارض يعرفون
جيدا وكنت معهم وهذه ايدي من اثار المواد
الكيماويه الحقيقه التي ضربنا
بشار النظام البائد يا سيدي الكريم اذا
اتينا من درعا كل المنافذ اصبحت بيد
ابطالنا ابطاء الميامين ابطال الجيش الحر
ابطال سوريا الحره ابطال المستقبل
ثمانيه وثلاثين نقطه الان هي بيد ابطال
الجيش الحر
باستثناء نقطه وحيده هي نصيب نحن تاركينها
لاوضاع استراتيجيه معينه اليوم يا سيدي في
هذا اليوم
حواجز تسقط اه من حواجز النظام بيد ابطال
الجيش الحر درعا كامله
كامله بيد الجيش الحر باستثناء كم حي داخل
المدينه درع البلد او
درع المحطه وخربه غزاله تعرفون الموضوع
الذي تم اه ل وستين ولكن استرجع غريب ان
ناتي الى دمشق ريف دمشق كاملا بيد ثوان
ابطال حتى الدليل قدمناه بمطار ه لا اتحدث
هو ولا ماليه ولا ولايه الفقيه ان ياتوا
الى دمشق عن طريق المطار الا خمسه برج
المراقبه نفسه ضرب في مطار دمشق والان
حركه الطيران مجمده واذا هو رجل يستطيع ال
المرور هو وميليشيات ال العبور باتجاه
المطار باستثناء فقره بسيطه عند ال
العربيه ناتي الى دمشق دمشق عاصمه بني
اميه عاصمه احمد ال ال الفاتحين اسمعوا اي
اياكم لن تقترب من عاصمه بني اميه نحن
احفاد الامويين اه دمشق الفيحاء في
القابون ملاح في بلد ملاحم في دور
في الحلقه الجنوبيه حتى مركز الشبيحه في
السته وثمانين الورقه لسنا على رقابهم
الان بشار الاسد لا يحكم الا داخل اسرى
الشعب يعني
يختار فقط ما اختار قصر الشعب بحراسه
لايران من الحرس الثوري المحتله سوريا اه
اذا ضمن دمشق ناتي نخرج من دمشق الدكتور
اذا خرجنا من دمشق
نتحدث عن كل الوضع انت سالتني سؤال تاخذ
الاجابه ال كان ياتي عليها بس حتى حتى
سيدي كيف ترد على هذا الكلام بسم الله
الرحمان الرحيم نبارك للشعب السوري
والحكومه
دكتور
علاقه بيقول انه
الشعب السوري البطل والحكومه السوريه
الوطنيه والخط المقاومه والممانعه هذا
الشهر الكريم واتمنى
سناتي الى عيد الفطر وقد انتهى الارهاب
وانتهى
المشاهدين
اذا بدك تشوف
خالد خالد خالد
من وياك بدون مقاطعه
بدايه
تفضل
فالحمد لله يعني
كل شيء في اخبار ساره للشعب السوري والقوه
المقاومه والممانعه سيندحر هؤلاء
التكفيريين والارهابيين الذين قطع الرؤوس
والايدي واكلوا الاكباد هؤلاء اولادي هند
اكله الاكباد الذين سيفشلون باذن الله
تعالى وسينتصر الحق تنتصر المقاومه انا
اقول لك شيء اولا يقول المطار انا يوم
الخميس كنت ودخلت المطار وذهبت الى دمشق
والاخوه يدرون جيده وذهبنا الى جرعه وصل
ينافي درعه كل هذا الكلام اللي قاله كل
كذب هؤلاء مساكين يعني يجلسون ويتمنون
المشكله في هؤلاء يد لسوريا ويتمنون
الاخبار الساره لكن هم يرون ال العكس ان
شاء الله وطبعا هم يعرفون جيدا اليوم ال
الشعب السوري مسيطر بالتعاون مع القوات
المسلحه لولا تعاون الشعب السوري لما تقدم
الجيش السوري ابدا ولا ال ولا بقى النظام
في سوريا والحكومه السوريه ولا بقى
الدكتور بشار الاسد اليوم واحد لولا
عليها انت شو دخلك بالشعب السوري انا مالي
دخل الصديق للشعب السوري كما الشعب السوري
يهتم ب ايران وهو منذ يعني الاربعه
وثلاثين سنه الشعب السوري وقف الى جانب
الشعب الايراني عندما غزا صدام حسين
العراق ايران وقف الشعب السوري الى جانب
ايران وكذلك عندما تعرضت المقاومه في
لبنان وقف الشعب السوري
على الوضع على الارض الحمد لله هناك تقدم
مضطرد لذا نراهم يستنجدون ويتسولون
المساعده الاسرائيليه والامريكيه
والخليجيه والتركيه فلذا انا اعتقد انا
اعتقد هؤلاء انتهت ورقتهم ثلاثه اربعه
كماشات كانت تدعم ال الارهابيين في سوريا
اربعه كماشات بالنيابه عن الكيان الصهيوني
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت تدعم
هؤلاء التكفيريين والارهابيين ان كانوا
طالبان ان كانوا الشيشان او اذا كان
الليبين الذين اتوا من كل مكان من كل حدب
وصوب اربعه كما اشاد كانت ثلاث كان ما شئت
انتهت بقيت كما شاء واحده الحكمه سيطرت في
الدوحه وفي قطر حصل ما حصل في مصر وذهب
مرسل
يناسب لانه متحالف مع السلفيين في مصرف
كان مجامله يعني
ايران كل ابواب
العلاقات مع ايران
تركيا حصل ما حصل وحصلت فيها المراجعه
بقيت السعوديه السعوديه لديها وقت شهر او
شهرين هذا هذا ال الوضع ال ماذا نرى احمد
الجربا يذهب الى السعوديه
وبعد ما اخذت سحب البساط من تحت القدره
القطريه في الائتلاف الان ذهبت الى
السعوديه لان القطر قطر غيرت رؤيتها
ولديها موقف جديد من الان فصاعدا بسبب
وجود الشيخ تميم سمو الشيخ تميم فلذا انا
اعتقد ان ما يحصل الان من اضطراب لدى
المعارضه والاقتتال اليوم نرى كيف بدا
التناحر بينهم على المصالح وعلى تقسيم
الغنائم فلذا هؤلاء الان الطريق الوحيد
لديهم هو الاخذ بالسلاح والمال والاعلام
من المملكه العربيه طبعا من من من صقور
السعوديه طبعا لا اقول السعوديه كلها من
الصقور السعوديه الذين ستنتهي ورقتهم خلال
الشهر القادم
بدون
بدون بدون يخليك لينا
معلومات معلومات
لاقول لك الرجل
خلال فتره قصيره في عيد الفطر سينتهي كل
شيء بالنسبه لم
تتضح الصوره باختصار شديد ستنتصرون على اي
حال المقاومه شاء الله انا ارد اولا عندما
وقف هذا الرجل الذي اه لبس عباءه الحرس
الثوري يدافع عن جماعه محتلين سوريا تكلم
عن مصر انا ادعو الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يهدا الامور في مصر
للاخوه الشعب السوري الموجود في ضيافه
الاخوه المصريين ان يكونوا على الحياد ولا
يتدخلوا مع اي طرف كان وادعو الحكومه
المصريه استغل هذا المنبر ان تيسر امورنا
السوريين وربما تاتي من ايام الرئيس مرسي
البوارج الايرانيه من قناه السويس محمد في
السلاح لدعم الارهابيين اهم الم
المنغوليين الحرس الثوري الجماعه بشار
الاسد ال البوارج الايراني محمله بالاسلحه
لدعم ابو شيء الصغير كذلك ترجع هذه
البوارج بشبابنا الاسرى المعتقلين الذين
يصفون في صحراء ايران وعندنا الاثباتات
والدلائل والوثائق والان نعود الى نقطه
المقاومه ارجوك المجال كما اعطيت يا سيدي
في اثناء الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه عام
الف وتسعمائه وتسعين التقى صحفي جزائري
اسمه المهدي بن محمد في مؤتمر صحفي كان
يشمل علي اكبر ولايتي وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه انذاك مع ملعون الذكر شمعون
بيريز وزير الكيان الصهيوني في اه اثناء
فضيحه ايران غيت في بريطانيا فكان لقاء
نوديه على الصحفي شمعون بيريز
طالما انتم اصدقاء وتدعمون ايران بالاسلحه
ضد العراق العربي لان هذا لا تقيمون
علاقات دبلوماسيه مباشره فاجابه شمعون
بيريز اما علمت انه في عالم ال ال العشق
والهيام والقرار علاقه العشق والقرار اجمل
من الزواج شبه علاقته
لان علاقه عشق وهيام اي مقاومه بعدين حرب
الالفين وسته هذا الموضوع معليش
مقاومه قطع لسانه لا يذكر كلمه مقاومه نحن
على الارض
اسرائيل
الاسرائيلي
لو سمحت ناتي اذا خرجنا من ريف دمشق
باتجاه عروس الثوره فهذا الطريق الى الان
الى عاصمه ابن كله بيد الثوار ان ما عليه
هو الان اصدقائي احد هديه ل عمليه نوعيه
قبل الافطار اتصلوا فيه م ريف دمشق وهم
يعرفون انفسهم جيدا بعمليه عن وصفوا فيها
خطاب حزب الله قبل ان دمشق شكرا لكم على
هذه العمليه البطله سناتي الى مدينه حمص
الوليد
بيد الثوار باستثناء احياء لبعض للاسف انا
اتكلم ب طائفي بعض النصيريين هم احفاد هم
عملاء حزب ال الشيطان وعملاء الحرس ال
المحتل وسوريا للعلم ايها الشعب السوري
يحكم سليمان هي محتله من هذه الشعبيه يا
ايها الساده كلها التكفيريين
ناتي الى والارهاب يد الثوار يشنون جنونهم
على الخالديه تعرف لماذا لان فيها ضريح
الصحابي الجليل خالد بن الوليد مؤدبهم
عندما
ياتون يتغنون في القدس القصير
قالي على قلوبنا واقول هنا قريه صغيره يا
جماعه وكبيره بفعل ثلاثمائه واثني عشر شاب
اربعين يوم يقاومون خمس دول من حزب
الشيطان
ايران الى دعم بوتين الان الى ال الصين
الى ابو متطوعي المالكي الهالكي والمهدي
والشياطين الارض قاموا ولكن انتظروا
واستمعوا مني ستكون مفاجئه مزلزله عما
قريب لا اريد البوح باسرار عسكريه في
القصير على
والزمن وبيننا اذا عرفنا من حرص باتجاه
تلبيس يا فنجد عباره عن كتله ناريه منتخبه
بيد الجيش الحر ناتي الى الرسم الاباء
تسمعون الملاحم فيها بيد الجيش الحر
ولكنهم يريدون ان يقيموا ياللي دويله
منسوخه مصيريه ولا هذا ابليس في الجنه
وهذا الرجل يقول انه يتضح له بعد شهر اذا
اذا انجب اثمرت شفافه جدا او اثمر بطيخه
ناتي الى ناتي الحمام حمام مشتعل من
الباديه حدود الرقه الى حدود جبال
النصيريين
يا سيدي الكريم والدليل على ذلك خسائر هذا
النظام
اللي كانوا
كيف ترد على هذا الكلام بدون مقاطعه كيف
ترد على ذلك انا بدي اسالك انت بدون تجريح
او
بدون بدون مقاطعه انتقلت عيد الفطر وضرب
تم اه مواعيد صح ولا لا ولكننا سمعنا مثل
هذه المواعيد كثيرا من طرفكم يعني قبل
اكثر من حوالي السنه اه النظام اه يعني
تحدث عن ام المعارك في حلب وقال خلال
اسابيع ستعود الى حضن الوطن اين هي حلب
الان حاله بعد سنه مازالت محاصره قبل شهر
اعلن النظام عن معركه اعاده حلب الى حضن
الوطن صح ولا لا
الشمال بالامس العالم كله تحدث عن ان
النظام وقف عاجزا عن ادخال لقمه خبز الى
حل بل انه الجيش الحر يطوق كل حال فكيف
حررت وعملت كذا وانت مش قادر
لا طبعا هذا الان المعلومه غير صحيحه وان
كسر الحصار وتقدم الجيش السوري والشعب
السوري المقاوم تقدم مع الجيش ودحر
التكفيريين والارهابيين والان هم يجرون في
كل مكان على حلف الان الان الجيش السوري
والمقاومه السوريه المقاومه الشعبيه التي
تساند الجيش السوري اينما ارادوا دخلوا
هناك تكتيكات هناك تنظيم هناك جدوله زمنيه
لهذه العمليات الان انا اعتقد هؤلاء ال اه
يعني التكفيريين والارهابيين الذين
اجتمعوا الطالبان فتحوا مكاتب ومعسكرات وس
يريد ان يساعد ولكن هذا قبل ما اكملها
تكفيريين
انتم في الشيعه بيكفوا اللي لا يؤمن
بولايه الفقيه
اللي
الجزيره والعربيه
بعض ال بعض الحلول وبعض
الحقيقه في حدث كثير
المشاهدين
انت يعني
انت تحاول ان
تركز في الاعلام هذا كلام غير صحيح
بال ولايه الفقيه
الموضوع من دمشق ذهبت الى ذهبت الى ذهبت
الى الى الى كل هذه المنطقه والدليل على
كل المناطق هذه بدات تحرر ال المشكله التي
تواجه الجيش السوري وال ال يعني المجموعات
الشعبيه التي تساندها والدفاع الشعبي هي
مشكله العوائل يحاول الجيش ال اه العوائل
وامنها اطفال نساء هؤلاء التكفيريين
يستعملونها الش الشعب السوري دروع بشريه
ويحاولوا عدم تقدم الجيش السوري ب ب بوضع
هذه العوائل امام الاماكن العسكريه
السوريه طبعا اذا شوف هناك تاخر في التقدم
بهذا السبب اذا حصلت تغيير او تاخر في اي
تقدم للجبهات هو بسبب وجود هذه الكتل
البشريه ولذا هؤلاء لانهم مرضاء على البلد
ليسوا سوريا غالبا
ايران ايران
وسوريا وحزب الله
بوجود اللبنانيين في القصير الذي بدا
التكفيريين
الارهابيين الذين دخلوا
هؤلاء هم الذين دخلوا الى الاقصاء
المنطقه
الوقت هناك تقدم واضح للجيش السوري هناك
تحرير لكثير من المناطق
الاحداث اشوف الان في حمص وحلب
القانون خلاص
وكذلك اه منطقه كباس وطبعا المنطقه الدوله
كلها خلاص يعني الان في بئر
هذا التقرير واضح من قبل شخصيه مهمه في
جامعه الدول العربيه
اليوم
يقول لك كيف ترد عليه عندما قلت انه اكبر
دليل على انه الجيش السوري ان تتحدث عن
الجيش السوري هذا السؤال هو سؤال ما بدي
الدخل اكبر دليل انه الجيش السوري انتهى
انتهى من زمان انه او البحر انه الذي
يقاتل في سوريا الان الايرانيون
عندما قال
تصدق عضو مجلس الشعب السوري هنا في هذا
البرنامج قال قبل اشهر اشهر قلت الجيش
العربي السوري خسر اكثر من مائه الف قتيل
بين ضابط وجندي بالامس تحدثوا عن خلال
اسبوع لاربع اسابيع تسعين دبابه اليوميه
على الارض في دبابات تذهب هذا الخطاب مائه
هذا الكلام في حرب عالميه
حرب عالميه على السوريه امريكا اسرائيل
الدول الخليجيه بعض الدول العربيه بعض
الدول الخليجيه بعض الدول الغربيه
داخله في الحرب علنيا بصوره علنيه سعود
الفيصل يقول
وكذلك وكذلك
البريطانيين الفرنسي يقولون انه ما نقدر
نعطي السلاح
العالم كله يساعد هؤلاء لكن ما عنده
ما عنده
الوطني
اللي عم بيحكي معلومات عن المعلومات
الان اه ال هم الذين يحضرون والكلام عن
انه في قوات خارجه من غير صحيح والتحرير
ماشي وانه انتم كل الدنيا تساعدكم ولا
تستطيع ان تحقق شيئا كيف
اولا اتى بشيء لو سمحت عطني مجال
هو يقول انه الجيش العصابه الايرانيه
والعصابه ال ال اه بتاعت المنقوله الاسديه
انهم يجعل تدخل المناطق ما استخدمت سكوت
ولا استخدمت البراميل ولا استخدمت
الكيماوي حرصا على الشعب بامثال هذا هذا
الشبح قاتل الاطفال هدول ما يحطون الاطفال
هذا انظروا لهذا الطفل البريء عصابات الحر
وعصابات المنغولي بشار الوحيد
هذه اطفال سوريا اللي حريصين على مجازر
الى ال ال
اه
كان يتبجح يتبجح بشار الاسد انه يا اخي
كان كان يتمتع بشار الاسد انه اكثر
المحافظات المواليه له هي الرقه وحلب خلال
اربع ساعات هارون الرشيد رجعت الى ثوبها
السنيه الاموي وتحررت باربع ساعات وكذلك
حلب الشهباء باستثناء ثلاثين او خمسه
وعشرين بالمائه منها اه هي ال اه التحركات
بحدود ثمانين في المائه لذلك سيدي الكريم
على الارض انا اتحدى الامثله ان تكون هناك
انا بعطيك
انا من اسبوع كانت
والله يا اخي ام ان اثني عشر من شهر
الابيض قالت لي دكتور اذا تحفر الصخر ها
ناكل التراب ولا كل الصخر على ان لا
تتراجع هذا الذي يقول ان اقرباء ونحن
العشائر احفاد الفاتحين
العجوز من دير الزور والله يا اخي انا
صادق في هذا الشعب الكلامي سالته اول ما
دخلت العمل الثوري يا عمان جدا امثال هذا
هذا الذي الذي يزور على الشعب السوري
ام
يا سيدي الكريم
والله عز وجل من دير الزور الابيه
درجه هذا الصهيوني المنغولي على دارفور
حتى السيد اه الجسر المعلق الذي اقامته
فرنسا وهي قوه احتلال راح عباده فهذا
العدو ل سالته او لاخر بالعمل الثوري يعني
هل تتوقع ان نجاحنا نظر اليها الاستقرار
وقال لي انت رجل وتضع حرب شوارع على وجه
الا تسجل وتستحي من هذا السؤال نحن حررنا
سوريا من فرنسا بالقيام والسلاح الفرنسي
ال اخذنا انتم يا خريجين الجامعات ويا
ضباط الجيش السوري وتاخذون السلاح وتصدروا
سوريا الثوره منتصر يا اخي اليك احصائيه
الاقصى اي عسكريه من الواقع تجاوز الى
الان عدد قتلى جيش النظام السوري ثمانيه
وستين الف قتيل ممتلكات الجيش السوري او
الجيش الاسدي خمسه الاف دبابه قصيره الى
الان ثلاثه الاف وسبعمائه دبابه يمتلك
الجيش السوري جيش بشار الاسد اربعمائه
وخمسين طائره
الان ثلاثمائه وستين طائره لا يوجد عنده
الا تسعين طائره كذلك يا سيدي الكريم اه
ال النظام يعتمد على ال ال الناس الشبيحه
والكذا اللي طبعا الحرس الثوري الايراني
هو المسلم الارث وحزب الشيطان قطعان
المهدي والمالكي الهالكي والمرتزقه دعم
الدب الروسي و جسر جوي مباشر يا سيدي
يعتمد على قطعه
المرتزقه الشبيحه من عندك من جبال
العلويين من اه شو اسمه
من ريف حمص من بعض كذلك حلب اما قتل
العلويين لا يستطيع الاعلان عنهم كي لا
تثور عليه ثوره داخليه اليكم مثلا اه اه
حوران حوران حوران عشرين الف عسكري في
الجيش السوري تسعه وتسعين منهم هربوا الى
الاردن اكثر من مائه وعشره الاف عسكري بين
ضابط وعسكرى اه من الجيش السوري من شقين
جرى ترقيه المؤخره بالشهر الاخير هذا
الشهر الاخير ثلاثمائه وثمانيه وستين
دبابه من مختلف الانواع ومنها
اثنين وسبعين
كرامتها على ارض الشام الابيه خلال الشهر
الاخير
اثنين وسبعين اللي
سلاح القناه الذي اخذت المعسكرات الش بشار
الاسد ومن
البلاد العربيه
حتى في المال يشتري السلاح لانه هم عارف
انه اسرائيل
قال كلاما عن
كيف ترد على الكلام عندما يقولون ان ريف
دمشق قاب قوسين او ادنى
يا سيدي كانت في الجزيره وانا الموجود
الان منها
القانون الان هي قلعه صامده
تعرف لماذا حنونه حمله على القانون اليك
دليل وهذا يوجد عشر الصحابي من الذين
خاضوا معركه تخلصهم من التخريب في هذه
الصحابي عند الابن الخاصه القادسيه كانوا
مستعدين عسكري لسعد بن ابي وقاص هم حاقدين
على القبول ولكن والله يا اخي يا اخي
ان ريف دمشق اصبح محاصرا اه
اه سبعه شهور يحاولون على اداريه استطاعوا
تدبير الحجر بجوازاتهم هذه اللي يدخلوا
فيها الجنه
يشوفوها يا شباب كيف عليك اداريه صارت
وتسع شهور لم يستطيعوا الشباب صامدون تحيه
الى رئيس المجلس العسكري في داريا العقيده
وهو يعرف جيدا فهم صامدون وابطال حتى
الموت برزت
ميامين واتحداهم اذا تبت هذه الكوتات
المحتلين اقدامهم مثل ستبذل القانون ملحم
يا سيدي دمشق هذا بدك لا يحكم هو الاعلى
قصر الشعب الان ثلاثه
انا اسالك انت تعلم ان ثمانيه وثلاثين
بالمائه حسب الاحصاءات السوريه ثمانيه
وثلاثين بالمائه من الجيش السوري المتمركز
في داعي
انت تقول لي نعم هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان
درعه شبه المحرره لم يسقط من درعه الا
خربه غزاله بسبب تواطؤ بين بين النعمه كما
يقولون والاردن سلمت العمليه باقي درعه
اللواء اثنين وخمسين المحاصر منذ اسابيع
ولا يستطيع ان طيب هل بقي موقع عسكري ذات
اهميه في درعه الاوسط
اليوم معركه بدات اليوم
صلاه الجمعه
ثلاث وهميه
هؤلاء هؤلاء ما عندهم شيء لا انت وحتى
الجزيره والعربيه
والله يا اخي
المشاهد
صحيح طيب يا سيدي خطر جبت وكل وكالات
الانباء اليوم انه تسقط
طيب هل تستطيع بدي اسالك اه قائد اللواء
ثمانيه وثلاثين
ماتوا للبنات
انا انا انا عندي معلومات عامه
انا مهتم بالقضايا
الاسلاميه والعربيه
انا باعتقد انا مؤيدين للمقاومه
التي تحرك
انا انا انا متعاطف مع الشعب السوري
والقياده المقاومه في سوريا
بالنيابه عن الكيان الصهيوني
الناس
الناس اللي تاخذ على نفسك انا اقول لك
الناس اللي
انا
انا اقول ان الوضع في سوريا خلينا معلومات
الوضع في سوريا منتهى شوف الان في خطه في
خطه صهيونيه امريكيه
بعض انظمه الخليج الفارسي دخلت
الخليج والعروبه
من المحيط الاطلسي الى الخليج
العربي
انا اعتقد ان الامر قد انتهى
المؤامره انتهت هي المؤامره شو كان اولا
تدمير الجيش العراقي من خلال الاحتلال
الذي ساعدته بعض الدول الخليجيه
النقطه الثانيه بدؤوا بتدمير الجيش السوري
من خلال هؤلاء
لانه في في قوى مقاومه في المرصاد
الاستعماريه ولا بهم في المستقبل ايران
ابدا ولا حزب الله ولا المقاومين ولا
الشعوب العربيه والاسلاميه
ان يتزلزل الجيش السوري والان في محاوله
ونتمنى ان لا تنجح ضد الجيش المصري كذلك
فلذا هناك ثلاث جيوش قويه حول الكيان
الصهيوني ارادت اه تدميره فلذا ايران لا
تقبل والقوى المتحده
نقطه مهمه طيب هل يعني خليني بس اجل هذه
النقطه طيب انتم تقول انتهى الوضع انتهى
على الشؤون انتهى على انه الشعب السوري
فهم اللعبه الخطيره
سوريا سوريا دمرت بسبب هؤلاء التكفيريين
والارهابيين الذين دخلوا الى
سوريا
البرنامج بدي اكمل معك حررت يعني التحرير
الذي تزعمونه الان هو تحرير المدن والقرى
السوريه من سكانها لم يبق ها هل تعتبرون
بسلام في حرب المدن انت تعرف انت تعرف انت
خبير استراتيجي في حرب المدن كل شخص متحصن
في بنايه بحاجه لمائه شخص من خارج البنايه
كي يخرج وه منها هيك حرب المدن في سوريا
لا تتم تتم كل كل ما يتم في سوريا على
طريقه غروزني في اه بضعه مقاتلين داخل
المدينه دمر المدينه باكملها على الطريقه
الروسيه لا هذه هذه طريقه قتالا بطريقه
جبانه لا ليست بهذه الصوره هذه الصوره
اللي انت وتنقلها في الجزيره
الارهابيين الارهابيين عندما ارادوا ان
يخرجوا من
الشيشانيين
والباكستانيين
هؤلاء اتوا الى هذه المناطق
والله
شوف الجيش السوري عندما يحاصر منطقه لفتره
طويله يريد ان
يعرف
نريد ان يخرج الاهالي بهدوء بامان
يتواجه ويواجه ال
الارهابيين مباشره
لما يخرج من اي منطقه كما حصل في مناطق
اخرى في دوما وفي موسكو يدمر ي يزرعوها
بالقنابل والمفخخات يدمروها ويخرج فيقولون
الجيش السوري هو الذي دمر المباني
هؤلاء
من الاردن نعم
بالم بالاسلحه الكيمياويه
المدن والقرى
تفضل تفضل السؤال هل تستطيع ان تنكر الان
ان الجيش الحر يتخبط والمعارضه قوات
المعارضه تتخبط بدليل انكم الان بدات
تحاربون ما بعض الجماعات الاسلاميه مع
الجيش الحر بدات تصفون خلافاتكم على هذه
الطريقه الامر الاخر
السلاح كل الذين وعدوكم بالسلاح لم يوفوا
بوعودهم بالاخر بريطانيا بالامس قالت حلف
الواحد لنزودكم بالسلاح بعد ان اكتشفنا ان
الجيش النظامي الجيش العربي السوري اه او
الكفه بدات تميل لصالح كيف ترد بمنطق
اسمح لي
يعني
اولا بالنسبه لل الجيش الحر الجيش الحر لم
يكن متفق جسم وكيان وكما هذه الايام تحت
قياده اه سياده اللواء سليم ادريس هو
عباره عن مؤسسه منضبطه ولها خطوطها الواسع
ووجود الميداني تحت قياده اركان عليه
الدوليه ومصلحه اخونا الغالي ميشيل كيلو
بانه سيكون بلسان الائتلاف عباره عن جسم
تنفيذي من عشره اشخاص او هيكليه تنفيذيه
لضبط جيش وطني اه هذه النقطه اشياء
الثانيه يا اخي لوقف العالم كله انا قلت
لك اه ال الكلام رساله العجوز اللي
لوقف العالم كله اللي بدنا بالسلاح اهلا
وسهلا ما بدنا السلاح نحن اخيره الله
الحين الحمد لله قمنا من هذا النظام شايف
على كيف
الحين الشباب يمتلك القدره المدرعات للجيش
السوري السابق
المدرعات كان عنده الحين من النظام يمتلك
الف وثلاثمائه مدرعه فقط وخمسه وخمسين
تطلع اثنين كيلومتر الى حالها توقع
باستثناء عنده اربعه واربعين دبابتي اثنين
وسبعين اي مهيئين عام ان شاء الله من
المالوف اخذنا ونجيب اجلها الطيران اكثر
من التحقيق الان عنده تسعين مقاتله سياره
موجوده وافقت
طائرات حوالي اثناشر يوم نوعيه او ما
تتدعي هذه الحوارات احسن ما اخترعت روسيا
بالعمل مع الطائرات اسقط ابطالنا الميامين
ثلاث دوامات كذلك يا سيدي النظام خسره من
اسلحته شايف على كيف باسلحه الحرب بالثوره
السوريه هذه هو
ومحتله عشر اضعاف من حروبنا بالثلاثه
وسبعين بما فيها حرب لبنان الى الان عشر
اضعاف الذخيره استخدم الاستاذ انا مع
الكيان الصهيوني وكذلك ايران من الثلاثه
وسبعين الى الان واه اسقطنا طائرتين انت
عاليات
التجسس موجوده ناتي الى موضوع ال بالنسبه
لل للخلاف وانا اعرف
الاخوه في جبهه
والاستشهاد اخوي يا اخي باختصار باختصار
ال اه طبعا الناس تنضم الى الجيش الحر
وجبهه النصره جزاهم الله كل خير وهذه
العباره عن ناس اخوه مجاهدين منهم
المخلصين واتينا يحررون من ال من حزب
الشيطان ومن اهلنا واهل السنه والجماعه
واتفقنا معهم على قيد ان تحرر سوريا وبعده
يذهبون يتوجهون الى بدا اما ما يشاع من
الخلاف هو عباره عن عناصر مدسوسه النظام
سواء في الجيش الحر او في جبهه النصره من
اجل تزعزع الامور وتعمل خلخله وخلاف ولكن
ال في جبهه النصره اعطونا اسم القاتل
وعملوا شخصيته وباذن الله
هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان المساعده اللوجيستيه
والعسكريه من حزب الله من ايران من العراق
من كل هذا لعبت دورا كبيرا في استعاده
الكثير من المناطق هي مناطق سعيده لا يوجد
منطقه سعاده الام سوريا
مازلنا على اعتاب الخالديه انت لماذا
تتهمون وانت رجل اعلامي هم استطاعوا ال
انسحاب تكتيكي من ابطال الجيش الحر في
القصير من اجل الحفاظ على حياه المدنيين
بعد خمسه الاف انسان ولا ما حماس ما زالت
الان لم يستطيعوا دخولها شنو نحمله حقدهم
على
انا ابن الوليد في هذا الشان لم تستطع ان
تناقش هذا وانت حي ننتهي من قذائف
انا بسالك سؤال
الان كل التركيز على حماس باختصار شديد
اخر الانباء قبل ساعتين ان الجيش الحر بدا
يستهدف وبدقه وبقوه اه باختصار شديد
احياء الزهره والنزهه العلويه هكذا يقولون
اه وهذا لعب دورا كبيرا في التصدي
لاشك ان الجيش السوري اه احتل اكثر من
ثلاثين بالمائه من خالد من الخالديه لكن
الطرف الاخر يقول ينتظرون فلا قصير
انتظرونا في القصير طيب الايام بينها ماذا
تقول لهم خلاص انا برايي الحل يقولوا ما
يقولوا الامر قد انتهى وحسن انا برايي
حلب الان في ال في المرحله الاخيره
امطار من
اخذه باقاله مطار العسكري بحدود يا اخي
شوف عم بحكي
الكثير السوريه
الجيش الحر من مطارات سد الفرات العظيم
توليد الطاقه الكهربائيه
الزراعه
الواقع انتظر يومين ثلاثه
مفاجاه في يومين ثلاثه
واقول على اساس العسكريه ولكن لا انا
اتحفظ على
معلومات
البرنامج
كما قلت لك
وخمسه واربعين يوم عن القصير في نفس
القصير حرمت انت قلت له لا
فلذا انا اعتقد ان المعلومات اللي لدينا
اقوى بكثير من المعلومات المضلله لدى
الامر
هؤلاء هؤلاء احتلوا سوريا
بسبب التكفيريين الذين دخلوا الى سوريا
سوريا
هذا الرجل من القبائل العربيه الاصيله في
هو الذي استدعى الاجانب هؤلاء امثال هؤلاء
حزب الله في الحدود
موجودين
الجيش السوري هناك والمقاومه السوريه
الجيش السوري
اولا انا مبارك وبارك الله لا انا ابارك
سيدنا خالد بن الوليد رضي الله عنه على
على ان المنطقه الذي هو
الجيش السوري
يعني هؤلاء طهرت الارض
خليني اسال سؤال اخير يعني في البرنامج
باختصار شديد باختصار شديد
ماذا تقول عن الوضع الميداني يعني كيف
تستشرف على المدى القصير جدا باختصار بجبل
بين يعني هؤلاء
المسلحين والمعارضه المسلحه والتكفيريين
والارهابيين هؤلاء الان بدؤوا يصرفوا
اوراقهم الاخيره يستنجدون بما البعض
الخليجيين الان وبعض الغربيين لكن لن
يصلوا الى ان
ان ياتوا الى الحل السياسي عليه مثل ما رد
عليه
باختصار اذا كتب التاريخ بدم الاحرار لا
يخوض الا ما والان اهلنا في الشام الابيه
يضطرون ملامه تاريخيه
معلومات
والشعب السوري انتظر من خلال الايام
المقبله ستجدون مفاجاه كبيره جدا منقسمه
الى شطرين شطر في حمص وريفها و سطر في
دمشق تزلزل الارض وباذن الله ان نصر انا
والنصر
الشعب الايراني بس انت ها الايرانيين
يضللون بكم هذا نحن شعب صديق ولكن ابتعدوا
ملايين الدولارات
تقول ان الشعب ستكون
مشاهدي الكرام لم يبق لنا الا ان نشكر
ضيفينا الدكتور خالد مصطفى واه السيد امير
الموسوي نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى
ذلك الحين ها هو فيصل القاسم يحيكم من
الدوحه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]